before we get into the new business that
you've developed you mentioned briefly
that you say you come from a land of
blocked writers ya hear about that yes I
come from the tribe of blocked writers
I've spent I at the age of three I knew
I was meant to write and I've spent a
long time learning how to write and
would always meet this walk where I
couldn't finish things and I couldn't
bring things to completion I would write
brilliant first acts and have visions of
the the end but couldn't get the whole
thing to work together so I developed a
process to break through that and
basically get people out of their head
and into their genius and it's the whole
idea of really understanding that if you
really want to write that internal guide
will take you but you have to stop
thinking so that the guide takes over
and it's it's a process of finding of
letting go of perfection letting go of
needing to know and exploring random
acts of genius by just taking whatever
comes to you and believing that the idea
that you have is enough to go forward
isn't that something that makes a writer
a writer is the person that just is
overthinking everything over analyzing
like this analysis paralysis a lot of
people go through yeah and there's and
especially when you're writing for a
living or writing because you want to
create a living there there tends to
have a place where writers thinking that
they need to meet the marketplace I need
to write something that'll sell I need
to write something that that will be
great and and if you think about it the
way the way artistry works the way
writing really works is that you're the
conduit and you're the toolbox and if
you can trust that what you have and
what you know is enough to finish the
story
and you allow like like having a tool
box so there's a tool box for suspense
there's a tool box for for creating love
there's a tool box for creating a big
finish or creating that page-turner
there's there's actual tools for that so
you can learn the tools but the story
itself is part of you and and the
moments are part of you and the big
thing is realizing that stories in
general are not plot we think they're
plot but they're not their emotions
their their moments that generate
emotion so if you become more concerned
with the things inside you that feel
like they're emotional and you get those
emotions on the page or in a scene then
you can find ways to create the internal
logic of a story to bring them together
so so it's just shifting from plot into
emotion really
you